so a lot of the ways that we represent
multivariable functions assume that
you're fluent with understanding how to
represent points in three dimensions and
also how to represent vectors in three
dimensions so i thought i'd make a
little video here to spell out exactly
how it is that we describe points and
vectors in three dimensions and before
we do that
i think it'll be valuable if we start
off by describing points and vectors in
two dimensions and i'm assuming if
you're learning about multi-variable
calculus that a lot of you have already
learned about this you might be saying
what's the point i already i already
know how to represent points and vectors
in two dimensions
but there's a huge value in analogy here
because as soon as you start to compare
two dimensions and three dimensions you
start to see patterns for
how it could extend to other dimensions
that you can't necessarily visualize or
or when it might be useful to think
about one dimension versus another so in
two dimensions if you have some kind of
point just you know off sitting there we
typically represented you've got an
x-axis and a y-axis that are
perpendicular to each other and we
represent this number with a pair sorry
we represent this point with a pair of
numbers
so in this case i don't know it might be
something like 1 3 and what that would
represent is it's saying that you have
to move a distance of 1
along the x axis
and then a distance of 3
up along the y axis so you know this
let's say that's the distance of one
that's the distance of three might not
be exactly that the way i drew it but
let's let's say that those are the
coordinates
what this means is every point in
two-dimensional space
can be given a pair of numbers like this
and you think of them as instructions
where it's kind of telling you how far
to walk in one way how far to walk in
another
but you can also think of the reverse
right every every time that you have a
pair of things you know that you should
be thinking two-dimensionally
and that's actually a surprisingly
powerful idea that i don't think i
appreciate it for a long time how
there's this back and forth between
pairs of numbers and points in space and
it lets you visualize things you didn't
think you could visualize or lets you
understand things that are inherently
visual just by kind of going back and
forth and in three dimensions there's a
similar dichotomy but between triplets
of points and
points in three-dimensional space so let
me just let me just plop down a point in
three-dimensional space here
and it's hard to get a feel for exactly
where it is until you move things around
this is one thing that makes three
dimensions hard as you can't really draw
it without moving it around or showing
showing a difference in perspective in
various ways
but we describe points like this again
with
a set of coordinates but this time it's
a triplet
and this particular point
i happen to know is one two
five and what those numbers are telling
you is
how far to move parallel to each axis
so just like with two dimensions we have
an x-axis
and a y-axis
but now there's a third axis that's
perpendicular to both of them and moves
us into that third dimension the z-axis
and the first number in our coordinate
is going to tell us how far we can't
move those guys
how far we need to move in the x
direction as our first step
the second number 2 in this case tells
us how far we have to move parallel to
the y axis for our second step
and then the third number tells us how
far up we have to go to get to that
point and you can do this for any point
in three dimensional space right any
point that you have you can give the
instructions for how to move along the x
and then how to move parallel to the y
and how to move parallel to the z to get
to that point which means there's this
back and forth between triplets of
numbers and points in 3d so whenever you
come across a triplet of things and
you'll see this in the next video when
we start talking about three-dimensional
graphs you'll know just by virtue of the
fact that it's a triplet ah yes i should
be thinking in three dimensions somehow
just in the same way that whenever you
have pairs you should be thinking ah
this is a very two dimensional thing
so there's another context though where
pairs of numbers come up
and that would be vectors so a vector
you might represent you know you
typically represent it with an arrow
whoa
help help
so vectors
so vectors we typically represent with
some kind of arrow that's
this arrow a nice color
an arrow
and if it's a vector from the origin to
a simple point the coordinates of that
vector
are just the same as those of the point
and the convention is to write those
coordinates in a column you know it's
not set in stone but typically if you
see numbers in a column you should be
thinking about as a vector some kind of
arrow and if it's a pair with
parentheses around it you just think
about it as a point and even though you
know both of these are ways of
representing the same pair of numbers
the main difference is that a vector you
could have started it at any point in
space it didn't have to start in the
origin so if we have that same guy but
you know if he starts here and he still
has a rightward component of one and an
upward component of three
we think of that as the same vector and
typically these are representing motion
of some kind
whereas points are just representing
like actual points in space
and
the other big thing that you can do is
you can add vectors together so you know
if you had another let's say you have
another vector that
has a large x component but a small
negative y component like this guy
and what that means is you can kind of
add by imagining that that second vector
started at the tip of the first one
and then however you get from the origin
to the new tip there that's going to be
the resulting vector so you might say
this is this is the sum of those two
vectors
and you can't really do that with points
as much in order to think about adding
points you end up thinking about them as
vectors and the same goes with three
dimensions
for a given point if you draw an arrow
from the origin up to that point
this arrow would be represented with
that same triplet of numbers but you
typically do it in a column
i call this a column vector it's not
three that's five
and the difference between the point and
the arrow is you can think of you know
the arrow or the vector as starting
anywhere in space it doesn't really
matter as long as it's got those same
components for how far does it move
parallel to the x how far does it move
parallel to the y-axis and how far does
it move parallel to the z-axis
so in the next video i'll show how we
use these three dimensions
to start graphing multi-variable
functions